In this video, we are going to learn how to select between different models.
Before we do that, let's do a quick recap from where we left off.
With selected features using distances sampled over time,
we investigated how many features we should select.
We made sure we had enough data for the chosen features.
We used the frequency of the data, to validate that we have enough data.
We also wanted to make sure the data is good enough to distinguish patterns.
We did this by visually inspecting the scatter plots and
making sure that our chosen features will have a discriminating power.
We have discussed how best to choose our features and
how that can affect the final validity of our models,
through analysis of errors and model complexity.
Once we have a good idea of the features set and
a clear definition of the problem statement, we can build many different
types of model to identify different cars from our connected cars dataset.
We are now ready to make the statement of the model.
We want to use classification model to distinguish between B and F.
We can do so by using several different classifiers.
In this case, we have chosen three.
A LOGISTIC REGRESSION, a SUPPORT VECTOR MACHINE based classifier, and
a RANDOM FOREST based classifiers.
Each of these learning algorithms are a topic unto itself.
And we will not attempt to cover the basics of these, assuming you have used or
seen most of these topics in the machine learning course.
If you would like to have a refresher,
please look at the material in the instructor's notes.
After we build the three models, we will look at ways to measure
the performance of each model and then be able to make a choice between models.